let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
good morning good morning good morning
and welcome to day two of the january 6
insurrection public hearings coverage
here on the midas media network
we are live one hour before the hearing
the hearing will gavel down in just
just under an hour now
as we will watch to make sure our
coverage
does not skip a beat thank you for
joining us here on this monday morning i
know it is early out there some places
in the country and you're just getting
your coffee just getting ready maybe
popping some early morning popcorn
for all the witnesses that will be
testifying today in day two
of the january six insurrection public
hearings a lot of stuff happening over
the weekend with news and this morning
even but i want to recap last week
thursday the very first hearing where we
saw the introduction into some of the
evidence
into the january 6th insurrection and
the select committee's work
you know it's kind of funny
uh fox news and all the right wingers
out there were absolutely terrified
terrified that there was a television
producer that produced the show
well if you watched
if you watched this wasn't like some
kind of hollywood elite
movie this was footage
from what happened on january 6.
they just
i don't know
put it together in a certain order that
timed it so that people could digest it
in a way that was
timed properly
the other thing too
that they really
was freaking out about
is that people were gonna watch this
thing right right wingers are terrified
terrified that people would watch this
thing so much so that they kept
spreading around lies ah no one's
watching it see no one's watched we had
we had i think the total count is like
200 or 250 000
just here on the midas media network
just the midas mighty
250 000 i think is gonna be the number
and i don't know what today is going to
bring today might bring the same number
or maybe even more
but i just find it laughable
that the projection continues and
continues and continues
one of the moments though that i thought
was a great takeaway
and and and for our democracy not just
for us as pro-democracy people and not
just us who want democracy in our
country we do not want autocracy because
we believe the equity and equality of
all the people here in this country that
equity inequality is dependent upon
democracy autocracy will not afford you
equality and equity
and democracy is hard
it's difficult
just like sometimes it's difficult for
people to know the truth
and the truth of the matter is is that
bill barr
and ivanka trump knew that the big lie
was a big lie
a big
lie it's a big huge lie
and that is the that's the ultimate
point here
and that's why they led with that
evidence to show you that donald trump
knows that it's all [ __ ]
the whole thing is all nonsense it's
dribble
it's only
only the ability to subvert democracy so
he can remain the dictator the king maga
because they truly want autocracy this
morning on twitter constitutional
republic is trending
it's trending overnight you know russia
and you know they get things trending
overnight get it in the morning really
get these moglodites these [ __ ] eaters
these trump humpers you know get them
all riled up in the morning on twitter
about the words constitutional republic
as if constitutional republic can't be a
democracy you [ __ ] boneheads really
need to pluck your heads out of your
asses
and learn words for crying out loud i
guess we shouldn't expect much for these
people they're banning math in florida
because of the
crt voodoo
as if critical race theory has anything
to do with math
but we shouldn't expect much from these
people especially for them to know
definitions of words or know that of
course of course a constitutional
republic can be a democracy
if we i don't know vote and elect our
representatives
in our republic
this is really boneheaded type stuff
but this is this is the dribble this is
the lie that they continue to push that
we are not a democracy forget about
forget about fighting for democracy all
these libtards out there talking about
fighting for democracy and having
democracy being the shining city on the
hill they're full of [ __ ] because we're
not even a democracy they don't even
know that we're a constitutional
republic
it really is sometimes difficult to put
things into words
but sometimes it's not
and when you live in a democratic
constitutional republic
it is a democracy that's what it is you
boneheads and that's what the january 6
insurrection
the select committees in these public
hearings are going to try to show you
today with witness testimony because
that's why they're [ __ ] getting
constitutional republic trending today
the reason why it's trending today is
because today you're going to see
witnesses that are going to say the
president of the united states donald j
trump tried to steal your democracy
these witnesses are going to say these
things they're going to say these words
i mean jesus we have
we have a trump campaign manager
we have a political editor from fox news
we have an election attorney
and the united states attorney in the
northern district of georgia where trump
called to get him to overturn the
democracy to get him to overturn the
election
we also had the former philadelphia city
commissioner where they tried to
overturn the election that is going to
witness today that yes trump and his
allies were trying to take away your
vote they were trying to subvert
democracy they were trying to tear down
our constitution and destroy our country
as we know it
because
he's just a sore loser
so today
today
we will see witness testimony in the
january 6
public hearings
that will show you
why
a constitutional republic is a democracy
that's why they have it trending
on twitter
because they're trying to perpetuate the
big lie and it's not to us
i mean
me you if you understand that this is a
democracy you understand all these
things
you wouldn't have to
continue to guess
but they're followers
their delusional constituents
still need the big lie they still need
it they're still clinging on to it folks
maybe just by a threat here
and hopefully today some of this witness
testimony can tear that to shreds i'm
joined by my co-host and executive
producer gabe sanchez gabe it's early
where you're at but uh you are kicking
this morning how are you this morning
good good uh you know took the weekend
to rest up and here we are six am west
coast time
excited to see see what happens you know
right right it's it's going to be it's
going to be tick-tock today i think um
it looks like there's two panels the the
trump campaign manager and the fox
political editor so that might be the
first part and then they may go to a
break like they did uh on thursday right
and then do the second one then there's
three on that panel um so so i'm not
sure what their aim as far as the
direction of the testimony and the
direction of the questioning but i'm
sure we'll get a sense to them once the
hearing starts and we get into the back
and forth between the witnesses and
also
[Music]
the hearing committee so what's your
take on some of these witnesses what do
you what do you think we're going to
hear this morning
well like you said you know we've got uh
we've got the commissioner from
pennsylvania right i think that's
the person that was overseeing the
actual ballots and accounting of ballots
and then we've got the uh
the uh election attorney
um from uh is it georgia i'm trying to
remember there's five people um
yes so we have we have the first panel
is a former trump campaign manager right
we've got al schmidt former philadelphia
city commissioner so he was the one that
was you know in charge yeah that's on
the second panel right so i i think i
think what we're going to hear in the
first panel is
what the trump campaign's efforts were
to subvert the vote um you you see
the former fox political editor
um
you know we've seen these fox news texts
and you've done you've done some videos
on these fox news texts like yeah right
yeah sean anthony to mark meadows uh
laura ingraham the mark meadows so i
think we're gonna see some of that and i
and i would also imagine that the texts
that they have read out so far are not
even the
the juiciest ones yet uh i would imagine
that they've probably
you know found some good ones that that
uh liz cheney could read out early on
um during their uh
their hearings that they had
before right but for these ones i
imagine that they've really held on to
the ones that are really meaty the ones
that might be indicating more of a
coordinated coop especially between
those who are just correspondents at fox
like why are they having a direct line
into mark meadows kaylee mcnaney like
seems very odd you know we saw we saw
some new text emerge um in the thursday
hearing with sean hannity and uh kaylee
mcinnady the former press secretary um
where
where they this was after
um the attempt of coup on the capitol
the violent coup and they were basically
saying hey we we gotta we gotta pin this
guy in a corner he's gonna try anything
to usurp the united states constitution
here this guy's trying to be a dictator
right they were really trying to work
hard to figure out ways to make sure to
pin him up and make sure he did not try
anything
which you know
regardless we knew that was happening
because if you remember he was suspended
from twitter and it was almost like he
he was gone from the face of the earth
in those remaining days which was you
know it was a nice break yeah right yes
right right but but it was almost like
he just poof was was not
he didn't exist all of a sudden not just
not just on twitter but i mean he wasn't
giving appearances we weren't hearing
much um it seemed as if that he was
lamenting um not just in his loss of the
election but in his loss of stealing the
election as well um so i think maybe
maybe we'll hear some of that testimony
um
but i think today in the second half
when we're talking about the election
attorney the u.s attorney from the
northern district of georgia where he
tried to pressure them into the eleven
thousand votes you know you know that's
right right
find me those votes and i think that's a
you know i think there were
conversations i think things got
released over the weekend i was
basically saying like we have enough
evidence to indict trump right well so
obviously georgia is one of those states
where it's like there's a we have a good
celebrity smoking gun right with that
tape where he's he's pressuring
ranthisburger to find those votes
because we're going to hear from i think
his name is b.j pock today
that's the former u.s attorney in the
northern district of georgia you
remember the news was at that moment
that he like just packed up his [ __ ] in
a box and walked out of the office like
he didn't he didn't give notice like a
u.s attorney would he didn't like have
this big long memo that he released he
just started packing his stuff in a box
after he got off the phone and walked
out of the office like people in the
office even some of the people who were
close to him like where in the hell is
he going like he just he just quit and i
would imagine that um
we're going to hear today why that is i
mean there's speculation you could say
that someone was pressuring him to
commit crimes and he's like nope not
going to do that just the same way bill
barr
was pressured to you know get out in
front of a microphone and just say it
was stolen you know even though it
wasn't just say it was and bill barr is
like yeah i really would not like to go
to federal prison if we could get that
so
yeah it's uh you know just like we were
surprised that uh mike pence was the
person that would be the defender of the
constitution you know
uh you know having people like bill barr
and others who are like
nope i'm done like you know just kind of
picked up their stuff and just walked
out the door and they were good to go uh
looks it looks like it looks like we're
getting breaking news here um it says
due to
due to a family emergency trump's former
campaign manager uh bill steffen will
not be testifying this morning now
wasn't he the one that was supposed to
come that was under subpoena uh it says
because of of family emergency no no i'm
saying uh he was only showing up yeah
under subpoena i believe so uh his
counsel will appear and make a statement
on the record the hearing is delayed 30
to 45 minutes so we have so we're we're
going to be delayed about 30 to 45
minutes here um and and the news is here
that bill steffen the one who what gabe
is saying was uh so supposed to be
subpoenaed is due to family emergency um
gabe that makes me think that bill
stefan was gonna say a lot of [ __ ] that
was gonna be incriminating yeah um and
he's being pressured not to testify
maybe i don't know i i doubt i i
i really seriously doubt in an important
moment like this the old
oh my grandpa died type [ __ ] israel is
gonna fly and i don't know what my dog
ate my testimony well it hurt it it it
it does seem that way um at least at a
bare minimum here i'm gonna bring in
texas paul yeah stick with us real quick
real quick yeah um and see if you can
welcome our other guest uh behind the
scenes here but i'm gonna bring in texas
paul and see if i can get uh what he
thinks about
this uh latest development and texas
paul how are you thanks for joining us
i'm wonderful man i'm
super excited super exciting did you
just did you just hear this news that
the uh the trump's for and it really is
not surprising that trump's former
campaign manager is the one that's gonna
uh skip out on testimony this morning
that's not a big surprise i guess if you
took that list and wanted to say well if
one of them's gonna skip it's definitely
gonna be him um you know the truth sucks
and it sucks to suck and they suck i
mean this is this is not going well for
them and this is a sign of that what
what's your take on it
well i'd actually wondered which bill
stepping was going to show up because i
mean if you if you
are paying attention to to bill stephen
right now he is not out of the game he
is currently working for harriet the hag
who's running against
uh liz cheney up in in wyoming i mean he
he is still a player he is so it really
doesn't surprise me that he would pull
some [ __ ] like this because you know
like i said he he's he he may not be
representing donald trump right now but
he is literally representing a candidate
that's running against the chairman of
this committee and
you know i mean
it doesn't surprise me
that he pulled some [ __ ] like this to be
honest with you i i don't i think in the
end we're going to find out that it's
[ __ ] that somebody had an angina
attack or something you know
uh a what gina a what giant
an angina oh
or that's an old school word for oh my
chest hurts oh i didn't know what kind
of gina you were talking about i didn't
i didn't know if you meant uh his heart
hurt or you know he was just having
something
second thoughts i don't know i don't
know you know uh it really does
again this is this breaking news um you
know a lot of people are going to be
um yelling and screaming about this
today but it's not surprising to me um i
want to show you here the the
if i can get it here
the tweet that we have here
is from caitlin collins due to family
emergency trump's former campaign
manager bill steffen
will not be testifying this morning now
the committee says his council will
appear
and make a statement on the record the
hearing is delayed 30 to 45 minutes
so um
we thought we were going to do an hour
ahead but it looks like we're going to
do almost two hours paul
um
yeah oh i'm ready for it you know this
is this is what we do is uh two hours
every single day now i need to get you
on on my show and um get a get a good
texas paul ryan on my show is if the
audience is not aware uh we broadcast
every single weekday monday through
friday at noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch we
also simulcast from the minus touch
facebook page uh speaking of that we
want to thank the mizellas brothers uh
for letting us host these hearings here
as we're going through our broadcast
but getting back to um some of the
witnesses
i wonder i wonder if this gives anyone
else a gina type attack like you were
saying um to uh
to to usurp the the the panel today i
would doubt it um what do you make of
the former political editor of fox
coming on do you think they're going to
reveal what what was going on behind the
scenes as as sean hannity and and laura
ingraham was texting mark meadows going
oh please please this is going to be
horrible for us this looks terrible
please please please help us what's your
thoughts there
oh absolutely absolutely bill stepping
was going to be the only hostile witness
on this panel everybody else is here
to
stick it into donald trump and break it
off
every single one of them if you go down
the list even ben ginsburg who's alone
you know he's a legendary republican
lawyer uh when you when you're in the
deepest of the deepest chess pit of hell
and you need a lawyer and you're a
republican you call ben ginsburg um
he is not happy about what donald trump
has done because it's just destroyed the
credibility of the republican party and
yeah the you know you've got you've got
what is it i i don't even know how to
pronounce his name steerwall
uh chris steerwall coming on from fox
he is a former fox employee he has no
loyalty to these folks at all
um yeah i i i believe today is going to
be a definitely spill the team moment
i don't see
stepping in not showing up is not
doesn't hurt anything at all to be quiet
well i think it says i think it says
more than it then then it doesn't say
right that the former campaign manager
can't show up to testify that that their
me there's the fear of the truth there i
mean really this does this does
um get at the heart of what what is
going to scare these these [ __ ] eaters
is that this testimony is going to tear
down this big lie because i think that's
what they started on thursday right with
with queuing up with bill barr saying
it's all [ __ ] and his words not mine
i would have used much harsher words but
he said [ __ ] and then you have
ivanka trump saying i believe bill barr
and i think those two pieces right
if there could be
because there's a lot of stuff that
happened on thursday there was a lot of
produced video the violence on the
capitol but i think getting at the heart
of why we still have a problem in our
country with people
longing for an autocracy is this big lie
and it still is perpetuating right
they're still trying to soft coo right
there
with his nazi excuse me his his maga
rallies um and everything he's trying to
really trying to usurp
our democracy and what it means to us we
the people
and the big lie is at the heart of it so
if you take the big lie out of the
equation right
you're you don't have a trump 2024 you
don't have people even supporting trump
candidates at some point and i mean
people who are who are flying trump
flags right if they realize which they
may or they may not i don't know right
we don't know what this evidence will
bring we don't know what this historical
event will change minds in this country
or not i have a feeling it won't change
as many minds as we would like it to
but
if they really truly see that they were
[ __ ] lying to just absolutely lied to
and sold a bill of goods that is not
true and it was used and designed to
manipulate them to this delusion to
usurp and make him king
i think that might help and i think
that's what the committee's aim is here
and his former campaign manager not
showing up to testify to the truth oh
boy well that just speaks louder than
any words that he might say
i don't know well i i think it directly
has to do with the breaking news that
the
committee has announced that they
actually have enough
information to indict donald trump and
if you're bill stephen uh and you're
running his campaign
you know he is the general that is doing
this i mean donald trump may be like
jerry jones is to the cowboys where he
can't stay out of the business but bill
stephen really is the coach on the field
and all of this illegal crap
had to go through bill stephen at some
point so
for him to come testify today
he had to have made a deal with the
committee and then when the committee
comes out and says we've got enough
information to indict donald trump
that had to terrify bill stephen and i
am sure
this is not about a family emergency i'm
sure the family emergency is
bill's going to jail
and he's afraid of the deal he made i've
got some news on that they just sent me
a i was sent over a tweet here from
nicholas wu it says we're told it is a
genuine family emergency his wife is in
labor is what they're saying
um you know i again i don't i don't know
exactly
texas paul thanks thanks for joining us
i i really appreciate your insight on
this stick around i'm going to bring in
we're we're going to be a straight
shooter and i'll tell you if that's the
case then i'll take my words back i'll
be glad to eat my words hey me too me
too if if that is the case but i'll tell
you stick around because um i i got
someone i want to bring in here uh but
stick around for more commentary uh as
the news breaks here so thanks thank you
texas paul
i want to bring in real quick uh michael
popock everyone knows pope pac michael
popock from legal af how are you sir
i'm doing great this that was an excuse
nine months in the making
well i mean you know maybe maybe they
planned some things
um you know to have to i you know i
don't know if his wife is actually in
labor i have no idea uh it really it
wouldn't really wouldn't surprise me uh
from a trump campaign uh manager to lie
um their team to lie i mean we've seen
it time and time and time again with
these folks um so i don't know if it's
true i don't know what the truth is it
just seems to be
very very very convenient
well let's talk about let's talk about
bill stop being a little bit yeah
first of all he's not doing this
voluntarily he's you know there's going
to be a whole list of people today
including the
former assistant u.s attorney for the
northern district of georgia ben
ginsburg election lawyer extraordinaire
primarily for the bush and the
republicans um
and the fox news analysts uh chris
steyerwalt they're all voluntary
i did not get the sense from the media
reports that that bill sepian was
voluntary in fact i don't think he is
now he already gave
video
uh
video uh interview i was to say
deposition but video interview with the
committee and they know what he's going
to say
but him coming live on the show today
they may substitute
his video
interviews which you know they have a
production team there just like you do
just like you do tony so they're cutting
and pasting now or they're going to
bring them on another day
because the theme for today is obvious
from the
from the people that have been selected
first we're going to do
tr penetrate trump world
with the very last campaign campaign
manager
in bill cepian about
that the campaign knew that he had lost
had reported that he had lost to donald
trump that donald trump responded that
he wasn't going to believe it that's
willful
disregard that's willful blindness in
the prosecutor world
which is a bad thing for a defendant
that shows that you have intent that you
have willfulness
so we're going to do trump world first
with bill seppian we're going gonna do
fox world
there's a thumb in the eye just like we
did with ivanka and and jared in in his
world fox world and chris starwalt who
was the fox analyst who who properly
called the win for biden and was
promptly fired by fox news so it's a
profile in courage so you got fox world
telling trump that he lost and trump's
reaction to that which also shows
potentially criminal intent and then
you've got
corrupt interference after noon
i'll call it two more profiles
encouraged you've got the philly
commissioner
who's going to talk about the pressure
that was put on him
to fine fraud in pennsylvania and in
philadelphia where there wasn't any and
then the georgia the northern district
of georgia assistant u.s attorney mr
pock who's going to testify that he
resigned
here's a profile of courage tony
resigned after trump put pressure on him
to find election fraud in georgia where
he reported there was none and then it's
going to end the day
with the i assume the bogus lawsuits
taken on by none other than ben ginsburg
then who represented um
uh george w
in the 2000 election against gore who
prosecuted proper
lawsuits that led to a certain result in
the election and it was been very vocal
in his analysis of the 60 lawsuits and
other lawsuits that were filed by trump
that all of them were bogus none of them
had stood a a snowball's chance in hell
at succeeding and and here we have a
republican
political
litigator
with that gravitas who's going to take
on
all of these [ __ ] lawsuits filed by
giuliani powell jenna ellis and others
on behalf of donald trump donald trump
being at the heart of that conspiracy
that prong of the conspiracy and that's
what i think ben ginsburg talks about
today
i appreciate you uh breaking down say
excuse me there i had my mic muted um
the breaking down i thought it was i
don't know no no it was me it was me it
was me i'm i i you say running
production i'm i'm looking at twitter
i'm looking at the witnesses i'm
listening to you and i'm totally focused
i know i know i know i'm trying to i'm
trying to get everything going here you
know
when you have live news like this and
the the broadcast gets pushed 30 45
minutes most people would freak out oh
my god i got to talk an extra 30 45 but
you know me well i could talk for three
hours without skipping a beat it's just
going back and forth between twitter and
and trying to manage what i'm going to
say but um i appreciate you breaking
down those witnesses there that that
is super super super helpful to know
where these people are but do you think
rather
bill actually shows up to give his
testimony eventually um once his excu
excuse has expired um here because you
know maybe his wife will be in labor the
next nine months i don't know who knows
how long they have the video they have
bill seption's video and that's and
that's what i was just going to get at
doesn't it because i'm sure the
questioning that they were going to ask
him they would queue up right they're
not going to not queue up his testimony
and then question him based on his
testimony that he's going to tell you
why you're right i'll tell you why
you're right because the
prosecutors and lawyers on that panel
know that sometimes what we refer to as
a hostile witness a witness that you
don't have complete control over where
you have to go into cross-examination
mode or you have to quote unquote
impeach them with their own words you
have to have ready the video clips inc
in case because they don't he's not
friendly to the panel that's the power
of the testimony if they can get it out
is that he's not friendly
he's currently the campaign manager for
a trump-supported candidate for congress
so he does this at much political risk
he'd rather not be there so what you do
when you're a lawyer that's uh
cross-examining if you will a witness
who may go off the rails is that you
have clips ready from his sworn
testimony in case he says something he
said you know in the sworn testimony he
said the light was green and now he's
saying the light was red you say
yeah we you're under oath a month ago
and let me play that clip for you so
they're ready for him
um
whether he showed up or not the question
from a presentation standpoint today is
whether they think the power of having
him squirm
but yet answer each question against
trump is worth waiting for him to come
back live and do it in one of the
remaining fiverr successions or it's
like [ __ ] it let's just sorry to
paraphrase your show no no
yeah hey this is i'm producing this show
and you know that i i'm i'm all in favor
of uh it let's roll let's roll the tape
instead and you know the tape the tape
is very powerful what's more i mean
ivanka trump was never gonna give it up
live the way she did when uh you know
you know months ago when she's just in a
little room with these investigators
and that clip was very powerful
i i think i think
that was very powerful and you brought
up in the panel afterwards on thursday
you brought up her her testimony and and
going back i actually took the clip of
bill barr saying it was all [ __ ] and
then crammed it together like right
after he says that with ivanka saying
she believed the bar because i think
that was probably
in in all reality and and i actually
posted it on our pod twitter page and
said show this to your uncle earl and
aunt edna and and the reason why he said
that is like if if there's going to be
small little bits of evidence that
you're going to see
it's probably going to be the testimony
of bill barr ivanka trump uh bill
stephen this trump campaign manager i
mean these little bits of evidence are
going to be the stuff that's going to
if there's going to be evidence that's
going to convince people that it was a
big lie and it's all [ __ ] like bill
barth said then those little bits of
evidence are going to be the ones that
are going to get people to go okay jig
is up right it's it's it was it was all
[ __ ] you know what two two points on
that you're so right tony two points on
that one
um it's obvious but let's just say it it
also it also for ivanka it also
indicates implicitly
that she met
she was in a room with bill barr where
where bill barr
made these comments even though you put
the clip of his testimony next to her
testimony for her to say i believe bill
barr then as a special adviser to the
president she must have been in a
briefing or got a briefing report or saw
him in the hallway for a direct
conversation because she didn't get that
directly from her father so you know
this is the problem with oh i'm daddy
make me special advisor to the president
with my husband we want to be in the
west wing okay you're in the west wing
which means you're going to run into
characters like the attorney general for
the united states who's going to tell
you things like you got to talk to daddy
because he lost the election and this
fraud thing you know just like all these
sham republicans they call them they
call themselves rhinos fox is a sham
republican you've got you've got uh
who's not bill o'reilly who's who's the
guy that's on there all the time that
the the carlson no the other guy
um
well i i i mean i mean
how many liars are on fox news is that
what we're going to do it would be
easier to go because on the air on the
air they say one thing's for ratings and
so they can buy a house in the hamptons
behind the scenes they're texting 25th
amendment get your dad off of there
oh oh you're talking about sean hannity
sean hannity we need to take him out
you know tucker carlson too tucker
carlson behind the scenes
is totally
uh up front about the the charade that
he plays every week unfortunately it's
destroying democracy but for them it's
just ratings and you know how many
houses in the hamptons can i have right
well here's here's a tweet from rick
wilson um
and and rick doesn't hold back a lot of
times but i want to bring this up
because um rick is a republican or was i
guess you would say and you know he's he
started with the lincoln project but he
says quote unquote family emergency my
ass uh bill steffen ditching the
committee committee is not going to play
well um so so many out there are
thinking that yeah your wife may be in
labor but you know
this seems important too maybe i don't
know i don't know this is all things
played and labor can be a long time
unless she's you know the laborers have
to be confused with my wife is having
the baby now if she's not having the
baby now i i agree with him that you
know i'm not i'm not trying to crap on
somebody's beautiful moment in their
life however
you've been called and subpoenaed before
the gen 6 committee to give testimony
about an insurrection and the possible
seditious overthrow of this country by
the press of the united states your
wife's maybe going to have to have her
girlfriends hang out with her for for an
hour or two while you give your
testimony
right right well because i don't know
how long um this panel was gonna last
but it looks like they have panel one
panel two he was on a couple hours you
know right right well i mean i i would
surmise that they were going to question
um him and the fox news political editor
uh and they were going to
break and then bring the other panel in
because if you look at the two panels
the second panel is really more the the
meat and potatoes of the election you
had the election attorney you had the
u.s attorney from the northern district
of georgia and then you had the
philadelphia city commissioner so
they're the you know they're like the
nuts and the bolts of the
interference right right where whereas
the political editor and the campaign
manager are more the planning side of
the coup right like like so you can kind
of see how this was going to play out i
mean people are pointing out that well i
mean even the article from the new york
times
um is that that here's the let me see if
i can find it back here that by the way
they're they're reporting i'm helping
you out here tony yeah
besides the 45-minute late start because
of stepping in apparently his council is
going to appear and make a statement on
the record
um
what do you think that looks like what
do you think that looks like then
well see so you mean it's terrible for
him are terrible for what what do you
think is terrible i think it's terrible
for stephen um you know he's gonna
obviously he's getting tremendous
pressure
around the trump world
you can't be the campaign manager for a
trump-endorsed
candidate currently for congress and
expect us that you're you have not been
bombarded with phone calls about the end
of your political career ironically he
was to appear on a panel with chris
starwalt of fox who who did have the end
of his political career because he had
the temerity and the courage to to
announce
that the election had been won by joe
biden um
on fox news and i had seen that i was
like wow even fox news is calling the
race um you know what i didn't know is
upset of course trump was and
immediately started making phone calls
to all of his buddies over there so he
was to appear
you know uh on on that type of panel
this is not a profile of courage by
stephie and he's being ordered to appear
he did not volunteer to appear he
obviously doesn't want to be there he'll
find any excuse possible short of the
wife literally giving birth at that
moment he needed to appear today and i
think they're either going to say we're
going to make other
look i think they're they're not just
going to sit there passively
like a sphinx and just let the council
get away with a statement about he
really wanted to be here but they're
going to say he was he was subpoenaed to
appear today he has not appeared today
he did not get excused by the panel and
we're going to reconsider what our what
our next steps are about mr stephen
about whether we even want him to appear
or we're going to make a referral
related to him they're going to be i
think we're going to see a harsh
response by the panel because they have
to
defend their authority and not to have
people flout their authority to appear
when there's been a schedule there's
been an announcement it makes the panel
look bad so they're gonna have to pay
him back
now the question i have for you though
tony is do you think they roll tape or
do you think they wait for stephen to
appear
whenever
well i mean i guess that's hard to tell
maybe that's why they're delaying the
panel i don't know if they you know
because i'm sure they have a plan for
that first panel of how they're going to
roll out the
the the testimony because i would
imagine they're going to show testimony
from both people and give them
questioning on top of that testimony i
mean that's that's what i would do um
here is the new york times headline um
the house
gen 6 committee plans to use the
testimony of donald trump's own campaign
manager against the former president on
monday as it lays out evidence that
trump knowingly spread the lie that the
2020 election was stolen so um it seems
it seems and fundraised and and fun
that's i think i forgot to mention that
and fundraised off the lie now we have
fundraising fraud which is another crime
because if you say things happen when
they didn't happen and you use that to
line your pockets with donor money even
if they're gullible even if they're
willing participants because i love
trump and trump 2024 whatever that's
called campaign fraud and if i think
sempi stepping was the link between the
fundraising the can't the big lie
and and trump so trump knew that he lost
and and willfully used the lie to raise
funds for his purpose and for other
purposes so you're saying the the grift
is illegal is what you're saying
well you know it's not surprising these
these people can't stop criming they
they really cannot stop criming um you
know the other thing to point out i
guess about bill stephen uh
is that the campaign that he's working
on is the campaign apparently against
the primary challenger of liz chaney so
maybe maybe the fear maybe the fear of
being in the room of darth vader jr um
made bill uh second guess his his
appearing for testimony today and use
his wife's labor pains
as his excuse not to show again i don't
i don't know if this is real or not but
you know
popock if uh
if bill stephen was uh
indicted on crimes and arrested they
wouldn't let him show up um for his
wife's
for the
uh in his wife's labor and the birth of
their child um he would likely be locked
away so maybe maybe just maybe he's
trying to avoid that as well i don't
know it just it seems convenient in this
moment
where
bill himself is gonna sit and not only
we're gonna see videotape of his
testimony but he's gonna be questioned
by the person who he's running the
campaign against the primary challenge
well this is
well this is
it's it's clear for the media reports
this deputy doesn't want to be there he
was not a friendly witness he was
subpoenaed to appear you know it's a
ballsy i like it i like the ballsiness
of the gen 6 committee to pull in the in
your
your your second hearing your second
session an unfriendly witness who really
doesn't want to be there obviously
and to but but they knowing that is
exactly what i said earlier knowing that
they have prepared plan b and plan c
which is including
running tape of him they may just i
don't think they ever get bill stephen
uh during the course of this thing they
might have to make a referral they might
have to find a do another vote on
contempt of congress but i don't think
we're gonna see bel stephen again the
lawyer is going to put whatever shiv
into this process he's going to give
today right they're going to have to i
think now reading more as you and i are
you know real time here i i think
they're going to have to roll tape and
write video of his interview and i hope
they do and get to this and not let that
derail because you know then then then
the signal is out there that every
witness can totally screw up the gen 6
committee by refusing to appear and you
don't want that i don't think he was the
only adverse witness that they were
going to call a hostile witness so
they're going to have to start
setting a precedent which is going to be
well [ __ ] it we're going to run tape we
have plenty of tape of his testimony
let's let's let's torch him i agree the
popak i know you got to catch a plane
now that we're gonna have a big delay if
you can when you land uh maybe check
back in with us yeah i don't know what
you're trying to do but if if you got a
chance uh thanks for joining us i really
appreciate it we'll talk to you soon and
everyone go download legal af on all the
directories and follow midas touch on
youtube to watch legally up on
wednesdays and saturdays thank you thank
you thank you
see you soon
i want to bring up our next guest david
bender and david is a political
strategist he joined us on thursday for
some of the testimony but i think maybe
he'll have some insight into what the
house january 6 select committee is
thinking this morning uh david welcome
good morning good morning uh well you
know do you have us some news uh um
about what the select committee is
thinking you think or what what what's
your thoughts here on this the only
thing i know is that uh
it is very helpful that there is someone
who understands live television in uh in
the form of uh
their producer who
used to work with nightline good morning
america these things can happen at the
last minute you have to be prepared i
think
that we're going to see
i i think you're right that we're going
to see tape of bill step in i think
we'll see the deposition
uh
i do think they're going to come down
pretty hard and i think it's likely that
there could be some consequence for him
uh uh some possible referral
uh for contempt of congress
for
labor pains notwithstanding this
there should be some pain for his
absence of labor this morning right
he he could have been there and
one of the things i think we all
understood that
what could happen in this process with
hostile witnesses
and with
planning to try and
throw sand in the gears of this effort
is things just like this at the last
minute you know he was announced
yesterday pulled the rug out the
pressure as uh
uh michael pointed out is that there is
um
definitely a consequence for the man
who's managing harriet hageman's
campaign in wyoming
uh to show up in front of liz cheney and
make her look good that that's got to be
something that just came down really
hard on him last night uh and and
perhaps send his wife into labor who
knows what what i do know is that
i think the committee is prepared for
every eventuality i think that they
understood that this kind of thing could
happen there will be other
both within the
committee process and outside of it
efforts to throw them off their game
i don't expect that that's going to
happen i expect that what we're going to
see today is
in
45 minutes delayed start we're going to
see something
that is
just as effective and and perhaps in
some ways
more so because they can use this
as
an example of the contempt that the
administration under uh
he who shall not be named
uh displayed for all congressional
oversight
remember nobody testified during the
four years of the trump presidency oh i
named him uh
and that's that's that's what this shows
they they continue to have contempt for
the role of congress on the rule of law
and
his absence can be used as a hammer it
can be used to explain that now we do
want to get
the evidence that he brings of the
knowledge that that
it was a lost election that they were
trying to explain away something they
could not explain away which was they
didn't have the
boats
now stephen let's remember is is a man
of of great character he comes out of
the chris christie world where he
oversaw bridge gate
uh and and i think chris christie threw
him under the bus at one point it's it's
you know there's still tread marks on
this man right uh so look
i i'm not i'm not so worried about the
absence of bill stephen
at all i what i am
interested in is to see and i think one
of the witnesses
tony that we're going to see really pop
today
is in the afternoon panel is b.j pack
who was the former attorney u.s attorney
in georgia
and he was the one who
was pressured heavily
to go along with this election with
stolen business
did not
and without warning was fired
and and it is plain that he was fired
specifically for not going along with
the plot in georgia
so this is this is going to be important
today not only for what we're seeing
here and the potential for criminality
that could be referred to uh merrick
garland
you will recall that or
not only will you recall i know you know
that there is in fact right now a grand
jury impaneled in georgia correct
i am certain will be a witness there as
well and this is going to highlight the
fact
possibly probably if we're going to see
any indictment of donald trump
it's going to happen in fulton county
georgia i think you're right i think
this year if there's a possibility of
having some sort of indictment it's
there
um
i appreciate your your insight into to
build there um and giving another
history point uh on the um chris
christie part of his career oh yeah i
can't remember that you can't forget
that you know this was this was that
whole uh moment in time where
you know i was in new york and and in
that area when this was going on and and
uh
literally they chris christie
took uh uh
way ahead of of of uh the excesses of
trump
just said if they're not this little
community isn't going to be for me we're
going to shut down their traffic right
of course of course
so so with with that kind of political
sort of
arrogance and and uh and it's
interesting now that chris christie is
one of the people who is trying to say
that trump did not tell the truth and
was a lie so chris christie is
he's always been a funny character in
the trump story hasn't he i mean he has
his own story but in the trump universe
he has his own funny story because he
was even the guy who went and prepped
him for the debate
he got covered and almost died
absolutely right because you know why
not that's that's what you're doing in
trouble you go in and and uh
and he was
with his co-morbidities it was it was
really a risk actually but here's here's
what's interesting about him
is chris christie
pivots constantly he is he's really one
of those
you know 360 characters you can find him
at any point
on the entire circle
and this point where you find chris
christie is that he is saying trump
should acknowledge what happened and
move on from it and
he's
i think
again delusionally
uh hoping that that will make him a
national figure relevant again and
possibly a candidate for right right
right right well i mean i mean you know
they they always use these moments as as
their crutch and i think bill bill step
step in is is using this uh labor pain
or his wife going labor is a crutch not
to go and have to incriminate um not
only himself but also
um his party who is um you know
currently employing him in the thrust of
trumpism where he is actually
a manager of a campaign against the
person who would be questioning him by
the way um and i always refer to liz
janie as darth vader jr
maybe maybe that is why maybe that is
why this morning he's
he's uh deciding not to show up because
well
he might be a little scared i'm gonna
say that i would hope we could uh
suspend if not permanently retired darth
vader jr because i think she's oh okay
earning the role of a jedi here she is
she is a she's a warrior
and and you know it is
this is one where i do think
it's not a
i don't think i think it's eminently
clear to anyone
she's
likely to lose that congressional
primary by 20 or 30 points
she doesn't care
she's not thinking about her political
future
she is thinking about
the word that's been used is almost
obsessed with making sure that this
story comes out
and she's doing that for the good of the
country
i i've never agreed with her on
i can't think of a policy position i've
agreed with iran in her entire public
career
but this is a moment where she is
showing
uh
stature and
states personship right
she is truly someone who has met this
moment with courage
and absolute focus on on getting to the
truth so with that in mind i'm i'm going
to call her a jedi okay well i'll i'll
give you i'll give you i'll give you a
little bit of leeway here uh because at
the end of one of these movies darth
vader did make the decision to go
against the empire at the at at a key
moment so maybe it is maybe it is
you know there are people out there who
haven't seen all the movies well you
know maybe maybe maybe maybe it is maybe
it isn't um i i will i will tell you
though that one of the the most symbolic
moments here with dick cheney and liz
cheney in the storyline of january 6 and
trumpism and the january 6th select
committee is when on the one-year
anniversary they were the only two
republicans her being the only sitting
republicans standing with nancy pelosi
on the house floor i'm clearly signaling
to the new trump part of the party that
hey
we are not we are going to push back
against this and it was a clear obvious
because dick cheney darth vader himself
does not do anything
um does not do anything without cause
and without purpose and i believe he was
standing there with nancy pelosi and his
daughter liz janey uh for an absolute
reason it wasn't just out of
happenstance and with with him with all
the democrats in congress and no
republicans in congress except for liz
cheney it really was a remarkable moment
to show how far gone the republican
party is a a point i will note that uh
ron reagan
made in a video that is now uh is now up
on
uh midas touch and i encourage people to
take a look at that because he puts in
context
uh
what what has happened to his father's
republican party
ronald reagan would not be
even considered a viable candidate today
for the presidency because he would
never go along with this right
and and and one of the things that's
referenced in that video is the whole
idea
of the peaceful transfer of power ronald
reagan believed in that
and all republicans uh no matter
even george w bush
who was gracious to barack obama
uh uh
they're gracious to uh um
to barack obama and we've seen we've
seen this process play out in our
lifetime and going back to the beginning
of the republic
uh john adams handed over the white
house to thomas jefferson his mortal
enemy
but this is a time where
we are in a historical times what
happened with this
previous administration was something
that is so dangerous so fundamentally
against everything that allows the
social
compact to work and and our democracy to
work and it's it's things that we take
for granted like the willingness to say
you've lost an election when you know
that you have and that's going to be the
emphasis today with the two panels ben
ginsburg the republican expert who is
going to say no question he's lost so i
think we're going to get a lot today
we're going to get the department of
justice on wednesday
uh thursday we're
is still evolving but i'll say that you
know we should
and when we come back in and talk about
it perhaps uh we're now 45 minutes late
yeah yeah we should we should be about
45 minutes away from the committee
starting hopefully
well
let me see this uh uh what i want to do
is go uh take a little time to uh to
find out what they're saying now about
how they're going to handle this this
new gap and up having to come back with
you absolutely yeah stick stick with us
come back and i appreciate i appreciate
your insight and and and everyone go
watch that video um that ron reagan did
it is um he does bring up some very good
points um and and it's a great video to
show that that how our democracy the
even the history i mean he tells a
little bit of history in there about
that transfer of power and the republic
and how it how it ticks
it does the tick tock and can i can i do
a shout out to our audience here that
this gentleman uh i'm pointing in the
wrong direction
is responsible for getting that video on
the air oh well i i i
i actually gonna bring the person who
did a little more editing than i did i i
started the process
but there was someone
that's much more capable behind the
editing board than i am i i run the show
here but the edits
i got a few uh folks that i know that
are better at that david i appreciate
you joining us stick around uh we will
try to bring you back in if you got more
news thanks a lot
i want to bring in maybe the person
who's responsible for some of that
editing of that ron reagan video uh and
and his and his little bro i've got a
couple of myzella's brothers with us and
jordy brett how are you hey good morning
everybody good morning big day big day
for democracy i would say if it was
literally anybody else steering the ship
and i found out that the hearings were
going to be 30 to 45 minutes late i'd be
like utter what are we going to do here
oh i didn't i didn't even skip a beat i
know it tony i know these hearings could
be delayed like
three weeks
i'm excited yeah i'm excited that
they're tony tony 45 minutes
tony lives for the delays i get 45
minutes extra to talk this is fantastic
it's so funny i thought i thought popock
was a little tough on stephen for
missing out on the hearing
i've got to say because i i
well i think i think he's in the right
alley but you give us your opinion on
what you think about the labor thing i i
would say it's incredibly suspicious and
i had the same exact uh start to it all
uh the same exact thought when i heard
it however
if there's any excuse that i'm going to
accept it's that when your wife goes
into labor you stand by your wife's side
at that moment in time and labor could
last hours labor could last days you
know you know you never know so while
the timing is suspect i think it really
speaks more
to the fact that we are so distrusting
of everything that comes out of this
administration and everything that comes
out of trump world that you can't take
anything seriously that you can't
acknowledge
that anything is factual unless you see
it with your own eyes it's uh speaking
of reagan i think one of reagan's famous
phrases was trust but verify and i think
with trump i flip it around a little i
don't trust anything until it is
verified right right verify verify
before you even
you could tell me that it is raining
outside and i will not believe you
unless i see it myself i will in fact if
you say it's raining i'm going to assume
that it's a beautiful beach day
if someone in trump world is saying it
but if his wife is indeed in labor then
we wish him all the best i think the
committee is going to be prepared to
switch it as you know with live tv uh
you know they're putting on a show as
much as they're putting on a
congressional hearing so it's definitely
difficult to switch last minute
especially when that was your lead
witness that you were planning on but
they got a lot of other great people i
think they have step in on tape
i'm really curious to hear from chris i
think his name is steyerwalt he's the
former fox political editor um who was
one of the guys responsible for fox
calling arizona that night you remember
magaland
in total freak out mode that night
meltdown mode accused fox of you know
trying to because they reported the
results of the election of trying to
sway the results even though that's so
ridiculous and we got the b.j park the
u.s attorney from the northern district
of georgia and as david bender said very
curious to hear what he's got so there
you go you got the schedule here was the
original schedule here
yeah so i wonder what they'll do i
wonder if they'll end up moving somebody
else to start or if they'll start with a
statement
i have to imagine that there's a
contingency plan here i mean they were
so well prepared the j6 committee day
one on the on the first hearing that
i just have to imagine that they were
accounting for something like this to
occur i'm curious to hear ben's take
when he jumps on but brett what do you
think do you think there's going to be a
contingency plan here i mean i think
that's part of the reason for the delay
i think they always have a plan a a plan
b a plan c a bland i think i think they
always have the
right array of plans that they could
possibly go ahead with um i think this
happening uh 20 30 minutes before they
were planning to start i think certainly
throws a wrench in things but i think
they'll be fine i mean they're
professionals like david bender was
saying i mean liz cheney is
the biggest professional in the world
she
knows this stuff inside and out i think
we're in good hands with the committee
and i think you see how effective the
committee is being just looking at the
reaction from trump world over these
past few days i mean i've seen trump
world meltdowns in in my day of covering
this stuff but i haven't quite seen them
at this level
and you see it when they start targeting
things like not the things that are
coming out of the hearings but they try
to target like oh they're trying to make
a show of it by putting it prime time
why you know they're trying to kind of
they attack the process of it and like
the method of it rather than actually
the meat of the issue which is that
donald trump and his cohort tried to
launch an insurrection against the
united states of america you can't talk
about that so let's talk about how dare
they put this on at at 7 00 p.m at night
you know or well this morning it'll be i
can't believe they scheduled this around
bill steffen's baby being born i mean
they'll they'll stay think that that guy
that guy played the long game man that
guy put it along put it past him saying
that stuff this morning i mean really no
it's every stupid excuse in the book but
i think one of the things that i am
curious about and i really haven't
processed this fully is that fox um or
as uh ron reagan in our video called
them i think he called them the [ __ ] the
news we air propaganda network right or
some sort of that um fox is actually
broadcasting today's hearings at least
they're planning on broadcasting today's
hearings and so i'm very curious as to
what made that switch if it's just
purely a ratings play maybe in prime
time they'd rather have their talking
heads you know tucker hannity those
people speak do you have any kind of
inspiration oh yeah
um that and maybe maybe jordy can
comment on this as well i think when
when they put up sean hannity's text
messages when he's the one reporting in
that hour i think that would be a really
difficult situation to um you know it's
kind of awkward when you're reporting
and then the committee brings up text
messages to show how you're subverting
democracy what do you think jordy do you
think that would be a little awkward for
marketing you're the marketing expert i
think i think it would be a little
awkward but fox is unfortunately king at
their marketing efforts and what they'll
do is they'll just cut away from that
segment if that happens while while the
coverage is happening and they'll
they'll point to some other protest
footage and start blaming antifa and
this that in the third i mean fox is
just so intellectually dishonest day in
and day out it's just so incredibly
disheartening that
a large portion of this country takes
what they say at face value and that's
why i'm so happy what we're doing here
at midas media network making sure that
we're getting the truth out because
truth is golden at the end of the day we
need to make sure that these hearings
are publicly seen in any form that's
possible whether that's on youtube
whether that's on tv however you could
find it and listen and watch this stuff
like the american people need to get
this tony and i can't thank you enough
for steering the ship here man you and
gabe have been doing just such a
phenomenal job
well thank you i appreciate it and again
this morning when we got 45 minutes
extra to talk i was excited i know gabe
is definitely excited after the uh the
week and he had well i'm gonna bring in
someone real quick uh uh maybe we'll
bring gabe in here too but texas paul i
think has a question for jordy texas
paul
what do you got what do you got texas
paul this could be anything and the
minute jordy popped up on the screen
all of a sudden laura comes flying in
the room sliding by
and slaps a label on my cookies
oh he's getting it
what does it say what is it yeah what
the hell
i i had a whole
cookies in my studio now they're my
cookies
i knew today was gonna be a good day
thank you thank you laura
texas paul man i appreciate you i
appreciate everything this is this is a
good day this is going to be an exciting
day breaking news i was actually really
excited when i heard that we had an
extra half hour 45 minutes because
there's a lot to cover here there
there is and i mean this is just a
tremendous opportunity
well the the fact that that uh texas
paul's cookies turned into jordy's
cookies we gotta we gotta make sure we
get that in on the screen gabe um what
do you what do you think about some of
this that's happening with this delay i
i know i know you're super excited to be
on air for extra time here oh yeah i'll
take it give me give me those 15 minutes
you know uh no i i think it is um
it's a bit suspicious in terms of the
timing i will say that obviously you
know if this is true
then i hope that everyone is healthy you
know i hope for that uh but it it does
seem a little bit weird you know like
popock even brought you know brought it
up and
and so did uh david is like
you know there's a bit of a there's a
gap in time here where like we could we
could do both things we could multitask
in ways right you've got a doctor
you've got other nurses who are helping
you out you could quickly just
leave i'm not trying to are you saying
there's like a there's like a maternity
ward at the capitol
let's let the guy attend to his wife the
video
come on
i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
belittle labor anything like that i'm
just saying it didn't seem a little
inconvenient or convenient dave gabe he
played he's playing the long game he
plotted this out nine months ago
here's the time maybe i'm gonna probably
make it happen if we
i've got five kids and i will tell you
the first kid sure can take forever but
if this is the third kid or whatever i
mean you talk in the front seat of the
car
you're talking i mean a lot of cleanup
guys i mean it could it can happen
really fast if this is like the fourth
or fifth kid
i mean it could be you know loading the
dishwasher bam you know and then there
it is you know
it's fast it's too early for these
visuals well here's the here's the thing
here's the thing
is that
my take on it is this
is that women are way better than men in
the first place and i'm sure his wife is
better than he will ever dream of being
being so i would bet that she could
handle labor by herself better than she
could with him and her side this the
fact that we need to get to the the
heart of why
why they perpetuated the big lie and why
they tried to steal our democracy away
from us um
is probably way more important than
um you know rather he needs to be there
to
to help her with their labor pains which
i'm sure her being a woman is way
way more stronger than he'll ever dream
of being um to help this um
we got is there more breaking news here
um
has not been that long ago that bill
stephen was having an affair with
bridgette kelly during bridgegate so
i don't know i mean this
he may be having a baby this morning
i don't know
but it it's just really weird and
convenient that it's happening right
here
right now
um there's a lot around this guy that
gives him reason not to be here like you
said he's representing harry at the hag
up in wyoming um he's still a player
um
he doesn't really want to be here
because like you said i think tony you
it was you or david that said this is
career ending for him if he says too
much i mean this is this is way too
convenient for me i i i'm with brett on
this uh don't trust and verify the hell
out of this if there isn't a baby at the
next next hearing
i need to see that baby texas paul i
need to see that baby
here's here's the uh
this is a crazy what an insane broadcast
we have here on the midas media network
so i here i'm going to give you a a
silver lining to this all i think
that
everything now is going to be 100 under
the january 6 committee's control
because he could say anything at that
point when you ask him a question but
what he can't do is he can't change his
answers that are already on tape and
they have bill stephen on tape and i'm
assuming that what he said on those
tapes are pretty damning if after they
had those taped interviews with him they
then decided you know what this is a guy
who we want to put in front of the
entire country uh to discuss these
issues so i'm assuming what they have on
that tape is pretty strong and it will
be completely at the control of the
january 6 committee they'll be able to
shape the show however they want to
without the risk of a wild card moment
which i'm not sure would have happened
but it takes it takes that element of
surprise completely out of it now so
well let me let me bring in a well let
me bring in a lawyer here um and see
what his take is it look look big bro
ben is here um ben what what do you make
of this do you think do you think brett
is right that they'll be able to really
uh focus in on the testimony and uh show
why but the other thing i want to know
is what his attorneys are going to say
because apparently it's it's not just
he's not showing up
his attorneys are going to make some
sort of statement now it may be that hey
we had a family emergency but or do you
think they actually make something a
statement that has to do with him
actually
the testimony that he actually has
already given that they will possibly
show no i think his lawyers are going to
give a very short statement to signal
that there was a family emergency and
they're going to try to get in and out
as quick as possible so i don't think
the statement from the lawyers is going
to be enlightening but let me give you
from a legal perspective a lot of people
are talking about this bill step in not
showing up but from a lawyer perspective
what interests me the most are some of
the other witnesses who are not really
being discussed and let me try to break
down for everybody why i think some of
these other witnesses are important from
a legal perspective
we've all heard the name ben ginsburg is
going to be on the second panel today
now ben ginsburg is someone who led the
bush cheney recount efforts in florida
in 2000 against gore ben ginsburg is a
republican lawyer he's one of the chief
republican lawyers on election law who
every republican administration has
relied on for claims of voter fraud
where that's brought up by republicans
that's why ben ginsburg is being called
in to say what all of these claim he
goes he's going to say i know what voter
fraud is and what trump's claiming is
voter fraud is total bs again ben
ginsburg the key preeminent republican
let me mention that again republican
election lawyer will be testifying today
that trump's claims of election fraud
are complete bs then as an attorney i'm
also intrigued by the fact that you're
going to have another republican testify
today and this is somebody by the name
of b.j pack he's a ex-us attorney from
the northern district of georgia meaning
he is the top federal prosecutor
appointed by
donald trump in georgia
and why is that important obviously with
trump's calls to brad raffensberger to
find him the votes and threatening
raffensberger with federal prosecutions
if these individuals did not find trump
votes well when you threaten these state
officials with federal prosecution
who would be the person in georgia to
enforce those criminal threats it would
be b.j pack and b.j pack resigned three
days after the call between donald trump
and brad raffensberger he's also
mentioned by trump on that call as a
never trumper which is also kind of an
absurd accusation because trump
appointed the guy so you're going to
have b.j pack testify today and then
we've heard that it's going to be an
ex-philadelphia city commissioner al
schmidt
why is al schmidt an important person to
testify today al schmidt is the only
republican commissioner in philadelphia
again we see the theme here another
republican who had his life threatened
as a result of trump targeting him had
his family life threatened and he is
again a republican so while a lot of
attention has been put on this bill
stephen you asked me from a lawyer's
perspective what i'm interested in from
a lawyer's perspective it's the fact
that all five witnesses today are
republicans um have republican vote
fighters are either top lawmakers our
top prosecutors are top media executives
who are from the republican world who
are all going to testify today one by
one that trump's claims and spreading
the big lie were completely false it's
going to be surgical it's going to be
impactful and that's why those five
people are important and it was
important that i point out all those
other people because everyone all the
other networks are focused on stepping
and even focused on the stepian and the
fox news guy chris stylework but these
other people are critical for the
reasons i just discussed
so so jordy because i think i think a
big bro ben here is making good points
on the marketing of it and since you're
the marketing guru
here um tell us what it
what do you think it means that the
committee would in their marketing make
sure that this panel regardless of how
many of them skip out on the testimony
today for whatever viable reason brett
um would skip out on the testimony today
what do you think it says about the
marketing that they're going to have
five republicans testify against the
republican big lie what what do you
think what do you think it's a very tony
it's a very strategic decision right
there to make sure that we have five
republicans
testifying today there clearly the j6
committee is continuing with their story
their plot for these hearings which is
very smart and very well calculated that
they're going to get republicans on
record they're going to use republi
they're going to take a page out of
might as touches book they're going to
use republicans own words against them
and they're going to frame the issue at
hand they are going to write the
narrative for what happened january 6
and make it clear as day
that it was an insurrection attempt
against the united states that donald
trump was the leader of this and they're
going to use his own people his own
people tony to make this the city it is
so smart what they're doing and i just
can't
i'm so proud of of how this committee
has been operating so far and i can't
wait to see how it plays out today
well i think even with the breaking news
with them separating i think we're going
to get a lot of information here and big
news texas paul did you have something
you wanted to add yeah if you and if you
want to talk about what you and brett
were saying earlier how effective this
has been just take a look at what's
going on at truth social that built
itself as the free speech zone and all
that other [ __ ] that they were
saying when they were trying to sell it
you know they're they're actually
banning people from the site who talk
about this hearing
so you know this is hitting home and
then you've got bill stephen not showing
up and and
you know
fox news is continuously running bogus
excerpts i think they had what 20
million viewers for the first
hearing um and then fox has turned
around
actually saying on air oh it was a dud
it was a flop fox news would kill to get
20 million people to watch anything
you know i i really think that you have
to really just just
you could feel it's just palpable they
are just
terrified this is coming apart at the
seams for them
the first day just just the testimony
that it was
a big lie the big lie was absolutely a
big lie and i think ben is absolutely
right ginsburg
what whether you love or hate the guy
is
bar known one of the best attorneys on
the planet and he has been saying from
day one
this is garbage
stop it don't do this
and for him to sit up there today is
going to be devastating
to trump and everybody that's been
grifting this trying to make money on
the side
uh it's over it's it's over
well i i appreciate that that that
they're about uh pointing out um that
ginsburg love him or hate him is going
to uh is going to have a tough a tough
impact this morning um on twitter i
noticed that the russians i mean uh
manga supporters
were having constitutional republic
trending um i don't think that's a
coincidence right that this morning all
of a sudden constitutional republic uh
started trending i think i believe that
they wanted this to trend because in the
in the second panel they have the
election attorney they have the united
states attorney in the northern district
of georgia which ben pointed out was
appointed by donald trump and and and
the other thing too about that story
that gets me about bj pack is that day
he went into his office packed his [ __ ]
in his box and left and didn't even
hardly bj packed his [ __ ]
right that's right packed his [ __ ] and
walked out didn't even tell me when he
was leaving i mean i don't even think
the guy stopped off at the restroom to
change his drawers after he had the
conversation he had on the phone because
i mean maybe we'll get some testimony
today about what those phone calls were
about before he packed his box and left
um but i mean that's that's a big
that's a big what happened there also we
see this uh former uh uh philly uh city
uh commissioner as well talking about
the election because this morning the in
the second panel i believe the the theme
is gonna be we are democracy and they
tried to steal it right so on twitter
this morning
russian i mean uh manga supporters are
saying hey
we're not a democracy don't let them
fool you we're not a democracy it's a
con even though if you it's like
it's like it's not a sandwich it's a
turkey sandwich right
gotcha like exactly what are you even
talking about like it's one of their
like classic refrains they love to go
back america is not a democracy america
is a republic it's like yeah a republic
is a kind of
representative democracy and then i
actually got into this argument the
other day with
i don't even know why i responded to
this troll i never respond to charles
but i responded to one troll on twitter
who was going to me and they end up
sending me a link and they they send me
a link to the wikipedia page for
representative democracy because that's
what i sent them and they were like see
told you look at that and it literally
lists in the wikipedia page that they
sent me representing democracies such as
the united states this that the other
and i was like reread that buddy read
that and see what it is
america it's not a turkey sandwich it's
a roast i i don't even know what they're
saying anymore but i think you're right
though i mean all these trends you
notice you wake up to the trends and
they'll be going live at like four in
the morning east coast time because it's
like prime time for russia to push these
things and it's the perfect time for the
mag of people on twitter to be like look
people agree with me
it's like oh well it's the same kind of
stuff this weekend where they you know
they yell and scream about gas prices
which i think we should be pissed off at
the oil companies over gas prices we
should be pissed off about that i
absolutely agree that we should be
pissed off at oil companies because
they're gouging us for gas prices but
this weekend they have the trump boat
thing whatever the hell that is where
they sink the boats or something with
their flags that was the it was the
desantis boat parade this weekend oh oh
oh it was desantis yeah yeah yeah
so there it is they're gonna be like a
battle between the i mean
the trump boat parade crawled
or walked
so the desantis boat parade could run i
mean that's that he they set up the
stage for this dumb kirk ii
the worst sequel ever so we're gonna
have the trump navy versus the desantis
navy is that what we're talking about
yeah i mean it's going to be a game of
battleship for sure i i'm excited about
the footage here really honestly are
they going to be throwing like bags of
potato chips and beers at each
no that's an air other that's antifa
that's antifa antifa are the ones you
know i've been straight forward with my
people about the gas prices and i think
we're missing a boat on branding this a
little bit because what's going on with
gas prices is we are again just like in
world war ii
we are sacrificing to send resources to
europe because we have a fascist
invading a country in europe
we are
supplementing what's been taken away
from them because of putin's price hike
and his murderous
illegal invasion of ukraine
we are selling more petroleum uh refined
petroleum products to europe than ever
before more natural gas than ever before
to try to help our european brothers
just like we did in world war ii that's
what this sacrifice is about and i
really think that that you know that's
what i've been telling my people
and i really think that we need to get
that on that bandwagon that this isn't
just a price hike this is the most
patriotic thing in the world you've seen
in your lifetime this is what it looks
like when a country
stands up against fascism
well here we see the the feed finally
coming in brett pointed out that the
fetus started um so i'm not sure exactly
when they're gonna start here but we're
gonna try to to bring it in as they
start it looks like um we'll probably
have another what 15 20 minutes and for
45 minutes behind are they are they is
there any um
is there any announcement out there on
the january 6 twitter page can someone
give can you check that for me to see if
maybe they've got an announcement if
they've set a new time um but we see the
the feed starting here i want to go back
to ben for a second um ben what what is
your take on not just today's hearing
but the
because we know kind of what the panel
was supposed to look like today but
thursday's hearing and then you go back
to today's hearing on top of that and
then what we're going to see on
wednesday i mean do you do you think
we're gonna miss something because bill
doesn't show up i mean do you think
we're really gonna miss anything as far
as uh what the actual aim and direction
is of it or do you think this is gonna
go off the 45 minutes was just to figure
out exactly how to present um the
evidence before the public uh because
bill's absence what's your take on that
i think bill's absence actually makes
this
more dramatic actually makes people want
to tune in more you know words getting
out right now across the internet you
know whereas this was supposed to be in
an early hearing lots of people were
saying well because it's early and
particularly early on the west coast are
people really going to be watching this
thing early like they did in the same
numbers as the first hearing i think him
not showing up
actually creates a level of kind of
drama
excitement interest
questions why isn't he showing up i mean
to most americans out there when you're
subpoenaed to court when you're
subpoenaed to jury duty when you have to
show up you show up
and
not showing up and then coming up with
the dog ate my homework excuse
even if it is one that is you know an
incredibly serious one is not something
that will conjure sympathy with the
american people who make sacrifices all
the time especially when they're
subpoenaed and have to show up at
proceedings nonetheless of proceeding at
this level so i think it totally
backfires on on them if their plan was
to not present him as a witness one the
jan 6 committee already has
his deposition testimony so they they
can just pull together the clips of
everything he's going to say
two it's going to create a lot more
drama which people are interested in and
by pushing this thing back a little bit
look it's now close to 7 30 on on the
west coast much more people on the west
coast are starting to tune in and so i
think you get a bigger audience frankly
because of this and then it's going to
drive people to watch the fox news
editor uh chris starwalt and then all
the other people that i that i discussed
well you know maybe maybe you got a
point there maybe it's a deep state
thing where they're trying to uh they're
trying to
they're trying to make sure that this
gets more prime time coverage um you
know maybe the deep staters and put
someone in the labor so that he would be
i don't know maybe they'll just keep
doing this until it hits seven o'clock
at night tony and then well it could be
i i may talk all goddamn day i mean like
i said tony this is the best thing ever
for you right now you and gabe are
living for this right now hey ben
question for you
can they bring sniping back in like like
i know the hearings are very well
calculated already and and and um like
the the hour blocks for each day are
already sort of agreed upon but
can't the j6 committee just bring
sniping back in for another hearing day
yeah they could bring
am i allowed to make fun of you in front
of the big broadcast that is absolutely
please no it's incredible
that's why you can get here on the minus
media network
so please let me know
make sure you do side by side of me and
ben as he makes fun of me um i don't
know it's okay
you combined the two witnesses chris
steyer walt and stephen and just called
them stipend yes
agreed i did that
and you do it you do it only the way my
younger brother could actually do it you
say it so quickly despite the fact that
we have like an audience of 11 000 or 12
000 people you go
star wars that one
okay
yes jordy they they can they can bring
bill stephen back in even though they
have this plan for the six hearings that
they have it planned for
um as they as liz cheney mentioned at
the outset she could bring you know
that conclusion of the hearings
doesn't conclude the work
of the jan sixth committee it concludes
these hearings but they can call people
back at any time if they want to hold
the seventh eighth or ninth they can
hold it remember jordan it's a great
question that you asked because there
are still court proceedings going on
across the country right now where the
john 6 committee's subpoenaing records
right we hear about the john eastman
case in the federal district court
central district southern division
which is in orange county california
where the jan 6 committee has been
compelling all of those records where
judge carter the federal judge has made
the finding that more likely than not
donald trump engaged in criminal conduct
um and so the jan stixx is actively
involved in still getting documents and
still getting and still getting records
i'll just read the comments
yeah yeah go ahead
i wanted to bring that up wants to take
on hashtag team jordy again he will
regret it as he has before when he has
been mean to geordi hashtag don't mess
with jordy this sounds like it sounds
like an absolutely new people listening
to midas touch jordy over there uh in
the bottom right midas jordy by far
amongst the three brothers ben brett and
jordy is the fan favorite if we ever
conduct a poll who is your favorite
brother jordy wins it usually by an
eighty percent margin so a lot of the
frustration that i give at jordan making
fun of him is based on his popularity
i'll just concede
do you see the cookies behind texas paul
right now ben do they say yeah cookies
no they do not they say thank you
i think jordy's making more enemies
because those the jordanians cook
cookies there texas paul's wife gave
those cookies to paul not for paul but
for jordan
and then it causes far more attention
here he can't even touch him and he's
right there in the studio and can't even
have any of the cookies so but here
here's the thing also jordy though like
i said
they'll likely play his video testimony
today as well so he is going to be
represented there and i believe what is
in that video i believe that will be
pretty damning in and of itself because
i think that if he didn't give anything
in that video i don't think they would
have even considered putting him on the
stand because they would have said well
he's a hostile witness he wouldn't have
anything to say he's going to ruin the
show and now they know we have this
footage on him it's incriminating and
this is going to you know we're going to
have full control over everything that
happens here there's not going to be any
wild card we're going to play this and
that's that i think ultimately they just
got to figure out they're on the show
because like i said it's as much of a
television production as it is a
congressional hearing so it looks like
everybody right now is
starting to get a little bit settled
there in that room i want to reiterate
to all the listeners here that this
midas touch feed that you're watching
one of the ways that it differs from all
the other feeds that you'll see from
other streamers and even from all the
networks is that this is a proprietary
midas touch stream so these cameras that
you're seeing the angles that you're
seeing are all exclusive here to midas
touch and that's why you don't see like
a c-span logo or you know another logo
we are getting this to you exclusively
for you for our listeners i want to
bring us to in the highest quality in
the best possible way possible so i also
just want to thank the production team
here i want to thank tony and gabe i
want to thank everybody and i want to
thank all the viewers for tuning in and
caring enough about this event uh
because our democracy is at stake here
and so i'm excited that the january 6
committee is going to expose exactly
what happened that day make the case to
the american people make the case to the
justice department make the case to
everybody around the world that donald
trump was responsible for the events of
january 6 and that those around him were
responsible for the events of january
6th and the deeper plot around january
6th to overturn our elections and stop
our democracy from existing
boom bret ran
for the next hearing though we will be
working on getting gopros for all of the
uh committee members so we can get an
inside perspective
i think we should have them on their
head so you can get like liz cheney liz
cheney cam you know right right you guys
it was hard enough to get the cameras
that way
right now that it gives me you know
stress just even thinking about more
cameras and the level of costs and
expense like what brett's saying too i'm
like yeah it's also incredibly expensive
to have your own
room
if we just put on the c-span feed it
would probably be oh my goodness
very important
that we do this in the most professional
way possible and everybody sees it from
these angles because i truly mean it i
was going back and forth to a bunch of
the other feeds in the first hearing and
our camera angles the midas touch feed
by far was the best feed the best video
quality and the best angles going back
and forth to the different people like
by far that's because you got the best
team over here i mean you gotta get you
got gabe sanchez and you got the tony
michaels handling that uh we have
nothing to do with the cameras by the
way there's nothing to do with the game
i'm completely exaggerating there but we
do appreciate you guys uh giving us the
opportunity to show this to the world
but i do want to point out something
here um brad had a great rant there but
boy in the chat here there is a back and
forth between uh
team jordy and ben here and even brett
um
i'm almost thinking about just
cutting out the feed and we just go back
and forth on this um
you know this brotherly feud that we
have we could do at least three hours on
the brotherly feud i have a feeling but
i'll say if you want to listen to some
more brother banter along with uh some
great news coverage make sure you check
out the midas touch podcast it drops
every monday and thursday night that's
the midas touch podcast get that
wherever you download your podcast then
it's a great time my brothers and i we
run that one uh we bring in some
childhood stories from here and there
but mainly focus on serious hard-hitting
news throughout the week to bring you up
to date ben looks like you want to make
fun of me what do you want to say well
i was actually going to say before ben i
was going to say they actually let you
talk on that podcast or i mean i don't
know i've probably spoken more words
during my appearance on here than i have
throughout the entire run of the midas
touch podcast but
i get in i get in my jabs here and there
well it happens ben ben did you have
something that you wanted to say nicely
to jordy yeah i was gonna say jordy
maybe to show everybody the shirt that
you wear
oh because
it's golden you know you know what's
going on merge midas gear
store.midastouch.com
use the promo code justice for 10
off we also have
it wasn't rigged you're just the loser
shirts and a bunch of other uh great
gear
but going back to today's hearing look
my expectations for today's hearing is
it's actually going to be more impactful
than the first hearing to me the first
hearing
as
impactful as blockbuster as it was that
was just setting the road map and they
intentionally held back
a lot of the drama a lot of the
fireworks
knowing that they needed to tell this
story and keep the audience's attention
over a set period of time and
again to all the people just tuning in
now what's so interesting about today's
panel about today's group is that
everybody who they called were
republicans so the ex-philadelphia city
commissioner al schmidt
was the one republican who sat on that
philadelphia city commissioner u.s
attorney b.j
republican appointed by trump as the top
prosecutor in georgia the top republican
federal prosecutor in georgia people
will be testifying today against donald
trump and against his claims of voter
fraud the top federal prosecutor i just
want to say how important that is then
you have attorney benjamin ginsburg the
top republican election lawyer
in the united states of america who is
the one who makes the arguments he would
be the he's the expert who republicans
call
on issues of voter fraud
he's their guy
he's going to be testifying today
that all of what the republicans say
about election fraud is complete bs he's
the republican expert i can't tell you
enough how blockbuster that's going to
be he led the recount
he led the recount for bush v gore for
bush
on election fraud
and he's gonna say
this trump stuff complete and utter bs
and then you got the fox political news
editor chris steyerwalt
and chris is gonna say
of course we called the election we knew
trump was gonna lose we knew biden was
gonna win i lost my job because of it
here are the threats that i received how
much more groundbreaking can you have
than that and then we're going to hear
some bs statement at the beginning by
bill stephens lawyer why the guy
couldn't show up to his hearing today
why he couldn't show up it's going to be
drama folks it's going to be
groundbreaking and it's gonna be hugely
important for democracy re mark my words
here today will be bigger news
than hearing number one
and what tony keeps pointing out
just goes to say exactly how much they
are just straight up crap in their pants
about this if they have to go back to
the old it's a republic not a democracy
[ __ ]
i mean come on red i mean that's the
best you got
really you know they are just getting
totally destroyed by this i mean day one
liz cheney poured gasoline
all over the manga nuts and just lit
them on fire
burn them to the ground and then you're
gonna see it you're gonna see it again
today i mean you can't stress i mean ben
truthfully truthfully is ben ginsburg
not one of the best lawyers on the i
don't mean to build him up too much
because i hate the guy because he keeps
beating us in court but
this guy is freaking good man i mean he
if if a republican gets sent to hell
and is sitting before satan and has to
be judged as to where he's gonna go i
guarantee you he calls ben fricken
ginsburg to defend him and satan's like
ah yeah
i i couldn't agree more but mark elias
would be the democratic version of a ben
of a ben ginsburg but you wouldn't call
mark for this hearing because
mark would everyone go oh mark's a
democrat but imagine
mark's adversary ben ginsburg shows up
and goes you know what mark's 100 right
on this one like well i'm with mark
that's basically what you're going to be
having here um but benefit but ben if
the shoe is on the other foot if the
shoe is on the other foot back to mark
elias if the democrats were sitting here
um with the finger pointed at him for
trying to overturn the government they
would have mark elias that's who they
would be calling in to testify so so
remember that that that our best
attorney if it was she was on the other
foot and democrats somehow would have
subverted democracy and tried to commit
a coup they would be calling him in if
if it were switched around so that's
what's happening we're calling their
best deterrent
to be our witness
against them right not just him we're
calling like a lot of their best
attorneys we're calling b.j pocket i
want our listeners and viewers to think
about this story at b.j park so b.j pox
in georgia he's the first korean
american in history to be elected to the
georgia house of representatives
and then he was appointed as the united
states attorney for the northern
district of georgia which is like the
highest honor to have as an attorney you
know you know in that career he said it
at the time and he was appointed by
trump
and then for him to go through this to
have this incredible career and we say
this time and time again
everything trump touches goes to
[ __ ] well i always say everything just
turns to liquid [ __ ] from totally
you know what
i want to bring back david bender you
might have some information on how we're
going to get started here the feed is
going i do want to bring up uh that
it looked like officer dunn was in the
room on the feed that's why i brought
the feet up to sea
i guess harry dunn as you guys know he's
testified uh before congress on the
issue of january 6
with his experience that day
um in there david you're you're uh
mutual might there um we but we've got
um
looks like harry dunn is in the room and
i'm not sure uh what the
exactly why but i seen him that's why i
brought up the female the officers are
are i think coming every to every
session finon is there as well
this they're there to bear
silent witness to this and to have
people say these are the people who
suffered the most that's why they're
going to be there i think uh all the
time
the here's what here's what we do know
they are going to use footage uh
from step in
uh the uh
the themes are gonna remain the same the
themes that we know
today uh they're gonna continue to uh
show that this was a massive effort to
spread
disinformation
uh and that you know trump knew he lost
and
worked anyway to put this information uh
this disinformation out to his people
and the consequences of that
not only did it it incite riots it
raised a lot of money
and that's going to be talked about
today um as we watch uh the hearings
start to gather and and when we see the
committee members go to their chairs we
know it's going to be time to to start
the countdown clock but
there's a they've got themes now that
are clearly stated this is what we
should be prepared for and be telling
people to to understand
uh when liz cheney said that there was a
seven part plan
these hearings these six hearings are
going to be used to underscore that
so wednesday we're going to get the uh
the justice department people the doj
and how the doj was used to be a part of
that we're going to get jeffrey rosen
richard donahue
people who were uh
actual fact witnesses to how the
department of justice was being used to
potentially corrupt this in the same way
that b.j pack will talk about uh the
pressure that was on him to go along
with georgia uh we know that this is
gonna keep coming back to mike pence
it's gonna come back to uh on thursday
we're gonna hear
uh from greg jacob we expect to hear
from mark short the vice president's
chief of staff former vice president
that the mike pence part of this
continues to be something
that everyone is going to see the
pressure on him was that final straw
that we're using to actually change the
outcome
to get what they wanted and and that's
setting this apart from this notion that
this all happened
in and around january 6. this has been
going on for months before went on for
months after is going on now and that is
the thread that i think they're trying
to tell the story of
i'm told that on uh tuesday on on the
last morning hearing that we're gonna
have we're gonna see
uh potentially brad rothensberger we're
gonna hear
about
georgia some of which bj pack will be
talking about but i said earlier i don't
know if if y'all could hear but uh and
when i'm talking to texas i say y'all
but i i will say that
it will be
uh
sort of continuing back to this uh
effort in georgia which has a grand jury
empaneled right now
and it is entirely possible that long
before merrick garland ever decides
to
indict any of the senior people here
uh that fanny willis in fulton county
will get an indictment this year
and if that happens then we're going to
see something that could in real time
affect the outcome i see chairman
thompson coming in
so i i think that means we are at that
point that the committee is prepared to
show us what they're going to do in the
absence of bill pepian but i think we're
going to see them on videotape yeah i
think so too and i think they had the
star wall there so
guys thanks for joining us stick around
if you can for the break um when we come
to a break if you guys are
up for a little commentary we will try
to do between panel one and panel two on
the break and then we will also have
coverage afterwards so uh audience stick
around for the break and for afterwards
if you can grab your popcorn grab your
beer whatever your whatever your fancy
is today or if it's jordy's cookies in
paul's case um we will we will come back
to that so thank you guys for for
joining us you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking